Chris Waters here with a Gamespot news
update Jade Raymond producer at Ubisoft
on such franchises as Assassin's Creed
and Splinter Cell has left Ubisoft after
10 years at the company today Ubisoft
announced that after 10 years of
collaboration the company and Jade
Raymond have agreed to pursue future
opportunities separately Raymond served
as a producer on the original Assassin's
Creed and was an executive producer on
Assassin's Creed 2 she also worked on
Watchdogs and Splinter Blacklist she has
served as Ubisoft Toronto's managing
director since 2009 Raymond said I've
spent 10 extraordinary years at Ubisoft
and I'm proud to have been part of many
of the best teams in the industry making
truly remarkable games this is one of
the hardest decisions of my career but
the Toronto studio is strong and on a
solid path I'm confident that now is a
good time for me to transition
leadership of the studio to Alex and to
pursue my other Ambitions and New
Opportunities stay tuned for more on
what's next for me but for now I'd like
to thank Ubisoft its partnership through
the years and I wish them the very best
in all their next Endeavors for more
news from Canada and other places where
video game news happens stay tuned to
gamespot.com